[Music]
skeletal replicas are excellent
educational tools
while real bones are fragile these
reproductions are made of a synthetic
resin
which is very tough
these models are scientifically accurate
and can withstand repeated handling in
classrooms or
museums
this facility is dedicated to producing
skeletal replicas
everything from ancient humans to
prehistoric animals
cast from real skeletons these models
are virtually indistinguishable from the
original
[Music]
the process starts with a real skull
this one is of a prehistoric
saber-toothed cat using a wire cutter
a worker slices up blocks of clay
placing the pieces on the skull
he presses the clay evenly around the
skull
he soaks a sponge and uses it to moisten
and smooth the clay
[Music]
he inserts a plastic tube that will come
in handy later
now he saturates strips of fiberglass
with the polyester resin
and drapes them around the clay
[Music]
left overnight the fiberglass and resin
cure into a rigid shell around the clay
he repeats this process to create a
second identical fiberglass shell
with the skull and clay in the bottom
half he bolts the second shell on top
he pours silicone into the plastic tube
filling the space between the skull and
the top fiberglass shell
after repeating this process on the
other side he opens the shell
he removes the skull and examines the
two-part silicone mold
he places the two-part mold back into
the fiberglass shell
and straps it to a spinner he pours
polyurethane resin into the mold
at just over a pound the weight matches
the original skull
[Music]
the spinner spirals at a controlled
speed
evenly distributing the resin throughout
the mold
after the resin has solidified he
removes a replica skull from the mold
the specially formulated resin has the
look and texture of bone
[Music]
the craftsman scrapes away the ragged
bits this part is the jaw
[Music]
using a special grinding tool he cleans
up the surface and does a bit of contour
work
[Music]
with a sharper tool he better defines
the area around the teeth
[Music]
then he grinds the rough bits away from
the cheekbone
[Music]
this is the jaw before and after the
improvements
[Music]
now it's over to the paint department
where a worker airbrushes the skull
using acrylic paint he layers shades of
brown
black and red to make this replica look
more authentic
he inserts the saber teeth in the upper
part of the skull
and drills little holes in both of them
he pushes nails into the holes to secure
the teeth in the sockets
[Music]
an inspector now scrutinizes the skull
and compares it to the original one on
the left
just like the real sabretooth cat skull
it looks ancient
[Music]
it's difficult to tell the difference
between the 12 000 year old skull
and the new one
the skull is now ready for the rest of
the skeleton body
[Music]
it takes five people three weeks to
build a skeletal replica like this one
you